I assume that it's gonna taste like a
lot of bad choices some ones that taste
like a hug I'm sort of hoping like an
alcoholic cow pole it says red wine
based aperitif the names on it wine does
not imply health give it a magically
made by monks okay high caffeine content
thirty seven point five milligrams per
hundred mil not be like hyper and drunk
there's free cards a red bullet in that
to the months oh that's horrible and
that smells horrible
whenever I don't like anything this I
thought touch it online
oh wow that is interesting
it tastes like ol Diego Meister free
pastors and medicine it tastes like wine
and then it's but it tastes good enough
for me to carry on drinking it you know
that film limitless with Bradley Cooper
where he can then access 100% of his
brain
that's why I feel like I think I'm
starting to like oh don't drink this if
you want to sleep for the next week is
the advice I would give
I mean 15% but [ __ ] that'd get you
pretty drunk this gets you shit-faced
quickly and it kind of tastes okay yeah
that's going down a tree though do you
think yeah I don't cool because you're
already drunk
Oh Oh
I'm not doing huh